So far in our journey through deep
learning,
we started with multi-layer perceptrons
that took our emnest images, flattened
them into a long vector of 784,
fed them into the input layer. And our
model learned
to classify them into one of the 10
digits. It was always 784 neurons in and
always 10 classes out a fixed rigid
contract. Then we moved on to
convolutional neural networks. The
superstars of image recognition.
We trained them on data sets like
imageet where every input image was
resized to a specific shape like 224x
224 pixels to be classified into one of
the 1,000 categories. Once again, the
input and output sizes were always
fixed. So there's a fundamental
constraint we've been working with up
until now. These models demand that our
world fits into a neat fixedsiz box. An
MLP needs exactly 784 features. A CNN
needs exactly 224x 224 pixels. So what
happens when our data doesn't cooperate?
What if I want to process a fiveword
sentence or analyze a 100word paragraph?
Or what about classifying a 2-hour movie
or a 15-minute short film? A standard
CNN or MLP architectures simply cannot
handle that. So the reality is most of
the world's interesting data doesn't
come in fixed sizes. Text can be a
two-word phrase like hello there or an
entire novel. This is the challenge
ahead of us. We need to build a bridge
from the fixed size world we know to the
variable size world of real data. That
brings us to our wall for today. We will
learn a powerful framework that can
handle inputs of any size. But for now,
we'll sidestep that a little bit uh with
a clever trick. We will learn to
compress them into a meaningful fixed
size representation that allow us to
return to the charted territory of fixed
input models. But before jumping into
complex tasks like machine translation
uh where we dealing with different
languages, variable length sequences and
all sorts of uh complications. Let's
start with a simple autoenccoders. Auto
encoders introduce a um an architecture
that we need without any really
complexity of having different types of
inputs and and outputs. The contract
here the autoenccoded contract is very
simple and the input X let's say of
dimension D for now like I said we can
have different size so one easy tree can
be if X can take different size we just
assume the largest possible size that X
can take and then we pad the rest of
those empty um dimensions. Okay. So with
that we have an input X and we encode
this using an encoder let's call it
encoder to another space uh latent
space. The dimension of this latent
space is much lower. And you can think
of it like it is basically the the
concept that X carries with itself.
And usually this is much has a much
lower dimension that uh X of course X
has many paddings and like for example
in t text we have punctuation marks and
etc. But the real meaning that this
piece of text is carrying is carry uh
has much lower dimension. So that's why
usually the encoder really compresses
the data. So to to compute the loss
often we have to either go to u label
space or a space that is uh similar to
the space of x. So in the simplest case,
let's just assume that we want to
compress the data and we want to
reconstruct it, right? So we want to
reconstruct X with the same dimension.
So we want the decoder to send back the
latent space Z to the original space X
hat. So in this case what we are doing
is basically we compress X to a latent
space and then we want this compression
to be in a way that we can retrieve X to
the best of our ability. So how we can
do it we basically want the
reconstructed X to be very close to the
to the original X. So some form of
distance between these two that we want
to minimize and this will be our loss of
uh this autoenccoder. So this is much
simpler than translation where we have
um input X for example in English and
the output in French which is a let's
say a different space or for example the
input can be images and the output can
be captions right again different spaces
so for now let's just focus on this
simpler architecture a very simple goal
we want to compress X in a way that we
can retrieve most of the information in
X later on. Believe it or not, you've
been using this all along, but of course
with a different disguise. Recall PCA
principal component analysis. In PCA, we
had a let's say D-dimensional input
after centering uh so basically mean
should be zero. We have some
normalization here. So after doing that
we encode or in other word in PCA we
project the data into the top k
principal components. So mathematically
this was where v was the matrix of
principal component vectors right and z
was the compressed code uh that was in k
dimension because of the k principal
components. So basically if you remember
when we visualized that it was like a
rotation that finds the the most
variation in X. So for example if your X
was like this and you had two
dimensional data it was enough to find
this PC which is now one dimension.
Okay. So how we can decode this? We
basically send this back to the original
coordinate which can be done by the same
rotation but the inverse right and here
since it's a rotation matrix inverse is
just a transpose. So PCA is simply
finding the best possible linear encoder
and decoder to minimize the
reconstruction error. PCA works because
compression works. The idea of
compressing data through this smaller
representation leads to a core concept
in deep learning the information
bottleneck. So in the case of amnest for
example we had this 78 784 dimension and
we encode this to for example let's say
32dimensional
um latent space which is much smaller
and then we could reconstruct the data
with maybe some blur but to some to most
of extent it's the same same image.
And this shows this information
bottleneck that we are talking about. In
other words, we don't want the model to
memorize everything, right? We want the
model to learn the patterns and there
are not really a lot of pattern here as
many as the pixel. So, we don't need to
really memorize the pixel. Instead we
learn the patterns which are much lower
dimension than that original pixels.
This way we enforce the model to learn
an abstraction
remove noises
and find structures. So I I encourage
you to review these PCA and how there we
find this vectors and through minimizing
the MSE loss. Basically we want to
minimize an MSSE loss like this.
Note that there is no bias term here in
this
uh linear
uh translations or rotation just like a
linear
feed forward neural network without
activation. So you could just similar to
what we did in linear regression. Of
course no bias. We have one linear layer
and another linear layer. So what if we
insert just like what we did for uh MLP
we can insert nonlinearity in this feed
forward neural network right so like I
said in PCA
we have one linear neural network and
another one here again linear what if we
add nonlinearity just like before and
add more layers so in This case, the
model is no longer restricted to
learning flat spaces. We've learned this
before. It can now learn to represent
data lying on complex curved manifolds,
not just linear spaces, but very complex
geometries. PCA cannot do that. But we
can do it. We know how to do it. We call
this an autoenccoder. Basically, a PCA
on a steroid. Right? So now we have
multiple layers with nonlinearity
and we do the same thing still we do
reconstruction still we want x and x hat
to be close to each other but this way
we basically find a representation of x
that is much richer and possibly even in
much less dimension because now we have
richer representation. So maybe instead
of 32, we could do much less for amnes.
Let's say 10 for example. Okay. So this
is basically a standard autoenccoder
that does the reconstruction. But we
could do more, right? We can we could
basically have an X and inject noise. So
a noisy X and we do the same
architecture, but we demand a clean X.
Okay. So this way we learn to clean the
data.
Or maybe we could do a supervised
learning. So so far everything here
could be unsupervised because we don't
need to really provide any label. We
have X and we just produce X, right? If
we have a label, let's say X comes in,
we find this nice latent features and we
want to decode this to some label in
translation. The input uh can be English
language sentence and the output can be
for example French which can have
different lengths and Z here will
represent the meaning of that sentence.
We will code a each one of this
architectures.